[Music]
I've been thinking lately about the
people this morning the Fulton Fish
Market a huge part of American History
this year the market is celebrating its
200th anniversary it has gone from an
open Exchange in lower Manhattan to a
giant refrigerated Warehouse in the
Bronx that takes up seven football
fields over the last two centuries the
Fulton Fish Market has provided jobs and
food for countless American families
while providing an abundant supply for
artists photographers and historians to
explore all of it we got the extra early
wake-up call
a.m at the new Fulton Fish markets as
the rest of the world sleeps this Bronx
building becomes a nocturnal City unto
itself
400 000 square feet of the ocean's
Bounty moving from Anglers who catch
food to chefs who prepare it so these
are local fluke off of Montauk this is
group over Florida you have black
grouper and red grouper Joe Guerrera
owns the largest wholesaler at the
market he's been doing this for more
than 50 years these aseps caught off of
Montauk this is tilefish
wow this is um what makes the fish
market and New York differentiates
itself from other cities The Fulton Fish
Market first opened in 1822 at the time
located five miles south in Manhattan's
Seaport District a place where people
could get all their groceries when the
Brooklyn Bridge allowed most commuters
to bypass it the wholesale Fish Market
became its centerpiece at its peak an
estimated two-thirds of all the fish
served in America came through the
Fulton Fish Market
serviced by dedicated workers of all
backgrounds and backstories for me
photographing the old-timers was
probably one of the biggest privileges
of my life Barbara Minch is a
photographer who devoted years of her
life to capturing the markets and its
characters I mean not only were they
tough men and I'm not talking about
tough in the sense of
uh intimidating you which they did a lot
it was the ability to withstand
the elements the Searing Heats and
bitter cold of an outdoor Market were
constant obstacles
though eventually not the only ones when
did organized crime get their hooks in
so organized crime appears for the first
time in the 20s Jonathan Reese is the
author of The Fulton Fish markets a
history its Origins are really obscure
it's not entirely sure how they did it
but how they stayed there is very easy
to explain they controlled the unpacking
and packing of fish in 1987 the Federal
Government tried to seize control of the
Fulton Fish markets to end Mafia
involvements an effort led by an
ambitious young prosecutor for the
southern district of New York Rudy
Giuliani made a name for himself yes
going after the Fulton Fish markets yes
yes and I'm I'm sort of of two minds
when it comes to that because he's
absolutely right and he made that case
over and over again that the Fulton Fish
Market could be cheaper if there was no
mob there but in order to get people to
cook the mob out he argued that the
Fulton Fish Market was completely
controlled by the mob and I think that's
that's completely wrong The Fulton Fish
Market didn't run because the mob told
it what to do it just paid off the mob
so they continue to make money Itself by
the early 2000s a real estate boom was
also sweeping New York and the smells
and crowds of the fish market were no
longer welcome
so it made the move Uptown many mourned
it as the last holdout of old New York
in its place today the same building
with a dramatically reimagined interior
these are the original Windows yeah well
those are those are replicas of the
original windows and the locations of
where they were and behind those windows
each Bay had the fishmongers cashier
this is the tin building now a tourist
destination curated by celebrated Chef
Jean George set for its grand opening in
September featuring six high-end
restaurants and six counters and delis
you can come here and get a prepared
meal or you can come here and have
dinner you grew up here I did I grew up
coming to the seaport in the 80s I
remember well and now you get to
recreate it what a dream Soul Cheryl is
in charge of Tri-State development for
the Howard Hughes Corporation where do
you want to take this place I'd love to
see New York come back alive late at
night I'm a late night person I love to
go out and I found that New York's you
know a sleep earlier than it ever was
especially post covet so where I'd like
to take this place I'd love to see it
you know busting with people until 2 A.M
in the morning when we close the city
that never sleeps took a nap it did
no naps allowed overnight back in the
Bronx
[Music]
refrigerated space in North America
where the middle of the night Mayhem
that has defined the Fulton Fish Market
for 200 years is still on full display
how many did you have
yet another generation will soon be
moving out and Joe Guerrera says his son
Anthony is ready to take over that's the
last of them we actually got out of them
we did pretty good what possessed you to
want to get up in the middle of the
night and work all night like your dad
so I remember when I was a kid and he
used to take me to work and we used to
the alarm used to go off at like one
o'clock he used to hop out of bed when
we would get down to the old Fish Market
it was just the buzzing the yelling the
screaming the freshness of the product
it was just a a hustle and bustle that
is just one of a kind you know you
really don't see it and uh it's
something that I really fell in love
with you know outrageous hours
notwithstanding it's hard not to fall in
love especially when they insist you
don't leave without dinner look at that
beautiful thing that's a tuna that's a
blue that's a bluefin tuna
yummy you're gonna have that tonight
and we did it we did have that that
night nice
um it's great and the I mean what is
amazing is the activity that is taking
place at two o'clock in the morning and
then by 7 A.M it's a ghost town wow
nobody left now do they take home dinner
well I would assume they deal with times
yeah yeah that's a pretty nice after
after a nice nap
at midnight it's interesting past yeah
yeah interesting backstory